well let me ask you uh
since he's probably he or she do we know
it's a he we have no idea okay I mean
that's another funny story about hackers
the he she issue what's the funny story
there well one of the guys in lulsec was
that was a she was a 17 year old girl
yeah uh and uh my source in the case the
the guy Sabu that I arrested and part of
it and you know we sat side by side for
nine months and then took down you know
the case and all that he was convinced
she was a girl and we said you know and
he was in love with her almost as at one
point it turns out to be a 35 year old
guy living in England oh so he was
convinced there's a uh yes he was
absolutely based on what exactly by
linguistic like human-based linguistic
analysis she she he uh whatever you know
Kayla is when it was ended up being like
a modification of his sister's name the
real guy's sister's name was so good at
building the backstory all these guys
and it's funny like these guys are part
of a hacking crew they social engineer
the [ __ ] out of each other yeah just to
build if one of them ever gets caught
they'll convince the everybody else that
you know they're a Brazilian uh you know
ISP owner or something like that and
that's how I'm so powerful well yeah
that social engineering aspect is part
of living a life of cyber crime or cyber
security and the offensive or defensive